l'assemblée nationale justement ce sont
les débats sur le projet de loi
séparatisme qui se poursuivent les
députés se penchent depuis hier sur ce
texte qui entend lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
au total 70 articles vont être à
examiner créé de 2650 amendements ont
été déposés
parmi les points d'achoppement lave
l'instruction à domicile la haine en
ligne ou encore la neutralité du service
public
je vous propose d'écouter ces quelques
députés la loi sur le séparatiste elle
va dans le bon sens mais elle va pas
assez loin sur des questions clés comme
le voile parce que le premier geste
séparatistes c'est de voile et sa petite
fille de quatre ans donc quand on vous
voit lé des enfants dans des poussettes
etc on nous dit que c'est pas du
séparatisme je sais pas ce que c'est et
puis deuxième point c'est l'immigration
c'est que si on contrôle pas le flux on
pourra pas gérer l'assimilation
tout ce qui manque c'est tout le volet
de programmation de rattrapage en ferme
éducative l'assertion président de la
république lui-même disait c'est sur nos
échecs que ceux nourris l'islamisme et
donc il faut réparer ses échecs ça c'est
pas dans le texte
c'est dommage parce que du coup il est
un peu unijambiste c'est à dire par
exemple que quand vous concentrer dans
les mêmes quartiers des gens qui ont un
niveau de réussite scolaire très
inférieur aux autres ou favorisées par
l'échec social par l'échec éducatives ou
favorisées en réalité le discours de
ceux qui disent la france veut pas d'où
c'est pas vrai mais et ça leur donne du
champ et il faut couper ce champ là pour
qu'il n'ait pas ensuite
des personnes un peu plus simple si
j'ose dire à retourner contre nous comme
des armes suis pas défavorable son
esprit mais en réalité c'est une une loi
qui arrivent à éviter quasiment tous les
problèmes donc elle fait mine de régler
le problème alors qu'elle ne règle aucun
c'est essentiellement une petite page de
promotion du ministre de l'intérieur qui
cherche à montrer qu'il est très très
ferme sur les valeurs alors que comme je
vous dis par exemple la question du
voile la question de la radicalisation
la question du terrorisme ils sont pas
vraiment évoqué